[Musik]
als jetzt geplant
weiter
[Musik]
in der blitzblanken abflughalle des
moskauer flughafens scheremetjewo dass
es acs speditions team wartet auf den
weiterflug nach kirgistan
[Musik]
um mitternacht landet die
aeroflot-maschine in osch im süden
kirgistans
das team wird von juice pack empfangen
dem leiter einer lokalen expedition
agentur
[Musik]
zwei nächte wird das expeditionsteam in
osch verbringen bevor es weiter zum
pamir gebirge im grenzgebiet zu
tadschikistan reist
[Musik]
mit seinen knapp 300.000 einwohnern ist
auch die zweitgrößte stadt des landes an
der ehemaligen zeiten straße gelegen ist
die satire und 3000 jahren ein wichtiges
zentrum für den handel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das getan
ja und st
das team fertig und 350 kilometer in
westliche richtung entlang der turkestan
kette einem ausläufer des pamir gebirge
[Musik]
kirgistan ist fast fünfmal so gross wie
die schweiz hat aber nur sechs millionen
einwohnern gerade der südwestlichen
zipfel des landes ist extrem spärlich
besiedelt
[Musik]
gegen mittag entdeckt das team eine
bäckerei an der überlandstrasse
[Gelächter]
mehr
das war
[Musik]
nach acht stunden fahrt erreichen sie
saß den ausgangspunkt der expedition auf
2600 meter über meer
[Musik]
es ist einfach wunderbar
unglaublich wir sind wir völlig
abgelegen allein auf der welt
ja das ist wirklich eine magische
erfahrung und die girls sind hoch
motiviert sie sind andauernd am lachen
ich denke das wird eine großartige
erfahrung
kurz nach tagesanbruch die kirgisischen
guides und esel treiber verhalten bis
das expeditionsteam bereit zum aufbruch
ist in zwei tages menschen wollen die
alpinistinnen dass mintal erreichen dass
tiger 1000 steinböcke dort werden sie
apps camp auf 3100 metern einrichten
wir packen die taschen für heute bevor
die tiere beladen werden alle
schlafsäcke kommen in eine tasche und
wir nehmen nur einen tagesrucksack mit
uns
fünf chinesische guides transportieren
die halbe tonne material des teams auf
30 eseln und rössern durch das gebirge
seid vorsichtig ok folgt immer den
guides
[Musik]
die frage ist jetzt ob er oder drei berg
hätten vier 1200 höhenmeter 80 kilometer
liegen zwischen ihnen und dem basecap
die gegend ist menschenleer nur
vereinzelt treffen sie auf hirten die
ihre tiere auf den kargen hügeln weiden
lassen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
am späten nachmittag haben die
expeditionsteilnehmer rinnen bereits
einen großen abstand zu den last ihren
und ihren treibern sind sie denn sagen
gegangen war akzeptabel dass drohungen
und toni wachsmuth und wenn wir es
eigentlich gar nicht dass die sinti und
roma liegt jetzt ein tool bei der frage
ob jetzt also das laufende minister
abstiege womit hause oder mit zerstören
aber jetzt noch bis auf der berghofer
und hoffe dass die doppel gruppen ist
[Musik]
mir ist es egal kann die ganze nacht
laufen ja aber wenn wir hinunter gehen
und sie nicht da sind haben wir keine
schlafsäcke aber oben ist viel kälter
es gibt kaum wasser wenn sie eben nicht
sind und wir gehen ins andere tal
hinunter und da sind sie auch nicht wenn
wir weiter gehen müssen alle
einverstanden sein
ich glaube beides ist fand wenig gibt es
einfach viele warnsignale da hoch zu
gehen an einen ort den wir nicht kennen
die diskussion zieht sich endlos hin
aber manchmal löst sich ein problem von
selbst wenn man nur lange genug darüber
reden da kommen leute
[Musik]
okay noch mehr sie kommen sie waren
einfach langsam und wir haben gestresst
sind wir auf dem richtigen weg und wird
schlaf bei uns hin und her und ich weiß
nicht genau wie es mit der kommunikation
aber jetzt einmal wasser und durch das
mittelland
die gefühle nach dem so lange ob sie
auch sehr symbolträchtigen gesten pass
hoch und hast keine ahnung was du zu
gesicht bekommen wirst weil du nur 20
bis 30 jährige karten und schwarz weiß
fotos kennst wir sind auf einer
entdeckungsreise
unglaublich
[Musik]
das ist spitze nadeln mit seemann
[Applaus]
übernimmt
[Musik]
wir werden erst morgen im basecamp
ankommen die isel gehen schon weiter
die rösser sind langsamer weil das
gelände hier schwierig für sie ist wir
müssen bei den rössern bleiben sie
tragen unser ganzes gepäck für das
campieren
wir sind uns einen anderen rhythmus
gewohnt bei uns heißt es gebe halte den
zeitplan ein
die guides sagten uns heute morgen um 7
uhr gibt es frühstück
also waren wir punkt 7 bereit sie
meinten natürlich 7 uhr nach
kirgisischer zeit nicht nach schweizer
zeit
wir hatten noch viel zeit unser zeug zu
packen
das leben von florence in der schweiz
ist geprägt von zuverlässigkeit
pünktlichkeit und struktur florence
steht im letzten jahr ihres
medizinstudiums war wirklich extrem
motiviert extrem fokussiert ist manchmal
ziemlich somit einen intensität und
wirklich es ist erfreulich
in der ausbildungsbegleitung uns wissen
dass die jeder weltweit aber auch in der
medizin
[Musik]
wie schwierig die ganze situation beim
hsv die angst das ist dass man eine
work-life-balance haben muss ist das
ganze leben lang kümmern
man darf auch aus meiner sicht gerieten
setzen das ist eine illusion
überall gut sein zu wollen dafür sendet
man sich kann man muss auch den mut
haben dann eine wahl zu treffen aber das
gute daran ist in der jetzigen situation
lernt sie wird sie viel lernen wo auch
ihren beruf dann wichtig ist im
kirgisischen chip total kümmern sich die
tier treiber vor dem ein achten um das
wohl der tiere
währenddessen versammelt sich die truppe
zur abendlichen besprechung
ihr habt diesen trip organisiert und
jetzt ist der realität
ihr habt uns alle hier zusammengebracht
das ist unglaublich stark sich etwas
vorzustellen und es dann zu kreieren
das ist wirklich speziell je mehr
wahlmöglichkeiten wir im leben haben
umso schwieriger wird es das härteste im
süden ist es eine entscheidung zu
treffen welche schule soll ich besuchen
in welches restaurant
man hat immer das gefühl den kürzeren zu
ziehen
merkt euch alles ist eine volk was wir
tun auch wenn ihr nicht die steilste
wand die schwierigste route den höchsten
gipfel schafft bringt die dinge in die
richtige perspektive
dann seid ihr am ende des tages
zufrieden
das expeditionsteam nimmt den letzten
abschnitt des weges zum base camp in
angriff noch einen pass gilt es zu
überwinden
[Musik]
ich geb
mit der kamera
[Applaus]
revanchiert
auch lilian hat es geschafft seit der
abreise von roche legte sich mit einer
magenverstimmung herum und hat mit so
viel ressourcen immer dabei hat
darum hat sie es aber gerade im moment
ist doch die anfangsschwierigkeiten mit
lecker
beim modus einer der kirgisischen guide
sammelt vertrocknete wacholder zweigen
[Musik]
das räucherwerk dient zum schutz und zur
reinigung und ist teil des uralten
schamanen wissens dass hier immer noch
lebendig ist
[Musik]
und vielleicht hilft es auch die
kirgisischen berggeister medien
zustimmen für die unternehmung der
schweizerinnen in den nächsten wochen
[Musik]
trotz müdigkeit und magenproblemen
erkundet das team gemeinsam die gegend
sie wollen ein genaueres bild von den
herausforderungen bekommen denen sie
sich stellen werden mit dem ungenauen
und veraltetem kartenmaterial war es von
der schweiz aus nicht möglich alles
wissens detail zu planen
[Musik]
drei ruhetage hat sich das team gegönnt
jetzt machen sie sich auf zu einer
akklimatisationstour auf einen über 5000
meter hohen berg
ein erster test für die jungen frauen
wie sie mit dieser höhe klarkommen
[Musik]
gerade lisa die seit einigen jahren
leistungs asthma leidet ist positiv
überrascht
lisa studiert maschinenbau an der zkb
lisa für sie endlich die tochter mit
neuburger und wird nur also nur 1 1
markieren aber gern selbst gemacht
frisuren es hat sich gar nicht gehen
kann sich erwarten sie von ihren
rucksack hat sich immer wieder sexy lang
lang hat sila zirka 75.000 will das ist
viel praktischer zum aufbau latte 21
minuten quasi tickende so tierschützer
das gefühl haben es trotzdem - alle aus
tierschutzgründen die autofahrer werden
kann falls ihre katze gehören dosen und
lisa könig
[Musik]
als gesuchter darin den stock retina
deutschland die beatles und jetzt auch
heiße zeuge schmeckt am schluss auch mal
nachwuchs
[Musik]
es läuft nicht mehr so schön
frankfurt
[Musik]
nach der zweitägigen
akklimatisationstour ist waschen und
körperpflege angesagt
der fluss vor dem camp entspringt dem
gletscher dass man theke und führt
eiskalte gletscher milch
letzte
die kirgisischen guides sind unterdessen
dabei den vorrat aus frischen brote
aufzustocken
ich will sieben kinder ich will 37 du
brauchst mir frauen
du hast 1 ich mache drei brauchst also
noch drei mehr
[Applaus]
sieben kinder und berge keine berge meer
für mich ja doch bergen
da bin ich glücklich
[Applaus]
das macht uns über die hätte ich schon
hinter mir hätte es um die andere zeugen
sich bei ihr oder ursachen
[Gelächter]
das team plant bereits die nächste tour
die kirgistan expedition bildet den
abschluss der dreijährigen ausbildung
die jungen alpinistinnen treffen ihre
entscheidung jetzt selbstständig
bergführerin caro gibt dabei lediglich
ein mögliches thema vor
euer nächstes ziel sollte die größte
herausforderung der expedition sein und
dann ein kleineres ziel wie zum beispiel
pikachu gegen ende des trips
ich denke der nächste gipfel sollte
einer sein der euch alles abverlangt
ich denke
der mann
eine möglichkeit wäre der gipfel hinter
asche wir nennen ihn der berg den wir
vielleicht schaffen
[Gelächter]
vielleicht sollten wir morgen starten
für den mint ecke benötigen wir rund
vier tage das wetter ist stabil die
temperaturen warm könnte cool sein das
zu versuchen
es ist einfach so dass die wand mit eis
und schnee ziemlich steil ist
wir dachten die könnten wir am
nachmittag bewältigen weil dann die als
qualität vielleicht besser ist die
verschiedenen möglichkeiten werden in
erwägung gezogen nach einer stunde
diskussion entscheidet sich das team
gemeinsam eine ambitionierte
erstbesteigung in angriff zu nehmen
morgen brechen wird zum neckar auf am
ende des gletschers werden wir ein
vorgeschobenes camp aufschlagen
am anfang der schnee hans es geht los
libyen ist seit ihren teenagerjahren auf
der ganzen welt unterwegs
libyen hat ein draufgängerisches
temperament
als sie klein war hat sie immer zuerst
gehandelt bevor sie überlegt hat mit dem
alter wurde das besser ihre reiserei hat
viel zu ihrem charakter beigetragen als
sie 14 einhalb jahre alt war ist sie
allein nach madagaskar gereist das hat
sie sehr geformt sie war auch in asien
in der mongolei sie hat alles bereit ich
glaube ein wichtiger faktor ist das
vertrauen der eltern im rahmen des
vernünftigen jedenfalls sie liebt was
sie tut
also werde ich hier auch weiterhin
vertrauen
gedrückte stimmung im basecamp median
und silvan plagen immer noch
magenprobleme
sie vermuten eine bakterielle
verunreinigung des essens dass sie am
ersten tag in osch eingenommen haben
im moment sind wir ein bisschen auf
standby
einige der mädchen fühlen sich krank und
haben schlecht geschlafen
sie haben vor allem magenprobleme das
ist ein konstantes thema auf dem ganzen
track jeder hat ständig magenprobleme
wir werden sehen was sie entscheiden
wenn es um die entscheidungsfindung geht
lasse ich sie lieber als unter sich
besprechen
so können sie frei kommunizieren und
dann sehe ich was sie entschieden haben
die jungen alpinistinnen haben einen
entscheid gefällt
sie wollen den tk heute in angriff
nehmen bewusst dass man sich nicht ganz
fit viele möglichkeiten gibt space camp
silvan bleibt im camp zurück er ist zu
schwach für die viertägige tour libyen
hingegen will auf keinen fall verzichten
[Musik]
geplant ist am ersten tag den einstieg
zum in theke hinter einem ausgedehnten
gletscher bruch zu schaffen und ein
erstes mal zu kämpfen
[Musik]
in zwei weiteren tagesetappen will das
team dann den gipfel erreichen
[Musik]
ab jetzt tragen die alpinistinnen das
material selber ausrüstung und nadeln
für vier tage
weshalb
[Musik]
die rucksäcke sind über 20 kilogramm
schwer
das team bricht auf in unbekanntes
gelände und muss für alle möglichen
bedingungen ausgerüstet sein
vor dem gletscher müssen die
alpinistinnen entscheiden ob sie heute
über den ersten abbruch aufsteigen oder
ob sich hier übernachten wollen
es ist nicht besser wenn wir uns das
erst mal ansehen und dann morgen wieder
hochgehen
ich fürchte wir gefährden unseren
gipfeltag wenn wir hier die nacht
verbringen
der tag morgen wird gigantisch lasst den
zehn minuten entscheiden ob wir mit oder
ohne gepäck hochgehen claro lässt das
team allein beraten
am schluss ihrer dreijährigen ausbildung
sind die jungen frauen für solche
entscheidungen selber zuständig sei und
wenn es nicht nach herberhold darum und
schlafen
das team macht sich auf den weg um die
verschiedenen möglichkeiten
auszuschöpfen
auf der linken seite des gletschers ist
gerade ein sehr heruntergekommen
das war eine unserer ausstiegsoptionen
jetzt haben wir noch zwei übrig
der beste weg scheint schließlich durch
einen gletscher bruch zu führen
[Musik]
der abbruch birgt unsichtbare gefahr
jeden moment können sich eismassen
verschieben
es ist eine verzauberte welt durch die
sikom
[Musik]
nach einer stunde in der ice schlucht
macht sich das team an den ausstieg wenn
sie die ebene hinter dem abbruch
erreichen dann haben sie ihr erstes
tagesziel geschafft hätte gereicht das
ja nachher wurde fertig
ramona ist in riga aufgewachsen und
studierte sport und
bewegungswissenschaften schon als kind
hat sie körperliche herausforderung die
ich komme mir interesse so zwischen 23
jährige zwei jahre kann ich in einem
weihnachtsbrief klatten artikel schon
glück dass nichts passiert und
darstellen aber nichts sie vor der
andere eltern dass ich das kind jetzt
dollar 78 meter fassade hochgeklettert
wieder opa oder der erde in regisseur
peter jackson die kritik sie während sie
in den aktien der da kocht oder
überhaupt das gemacht und plötzlich
ramona in einer kundin nachricht die
play-offs doch kletterten dass er
wirklich drehe ich dann trocknet die
haut offenbarten ohne dich du schöner
es wird also der grands prix in denen
gewählt
ich bin der meinung wenn es regnet
konnte das klinikum alter es ist
vermittelt werden wes bush und die
spülung staatsoper und wenn sie trotzen
die folter
die mädchen sind unglaublich sie haben
wirklich gutes teamwork im eis gezeigt
sie sind wie unter strom und
hochmotiviert libyen hat ihr
morgendliches unwohlsein überwunden
vielleicht hat das adrenalin im
angesicht des mit theke abenteuers
geholfen
ich glaube wir haben gute entscheidungen
getroffen
das war cool in der mitte des gletschers
super haben wir diesen weg gefunden
der morgige tag beinhaltet eine passage
über ein eisfeld und alle berge und
dessen gefährlichkeit sie vom ersten
camper aus nicht abschätzen können
[Musik]
lasst
also so einem spiel gar nicht prüfen
nämlich sie danach und die anfahrt und
der selber stelle heißt ja
ramona
nach der überwindung des türkischen werk
schwundes geht es weiter über eine rund
100 meter hohe eiswand in zwei
seilschaften um schneller voranzukommen
[Musik]
lisa kämpft mit sich und dem berg in
dieser höhe setzt ihr das leistungs
asthma zu an dem sie seit ein paar
jahren leidet
[Musik]
und auch die andere seite schafft erlebt
eine unliebsame überraschung steinschlag
[Musik]
versiert nach rechts
morgenland
[Musik]
der schreckmoment ist vorbei die
bedrängte seilschaft bringt sich in der
linie ihrer kolleginnen in sicherheit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der pass liegt genau auf der grenze zu
tadschikistan
[Musik]
wir haben den pass erreicht und hier ist
der gipfel
er ist nicht so nah wie das von hier aus
scheint es sind noch 800 höhenmeter
[Musik]
34 in der früh nach zwei tagen aufstieg
will das sc frauen expeditionsteam heute
den gipfel des mintec erreichen
[Musik]
rund 800 höhenmeter sind zu bewältigen
die geplante route führt mehrheitlich
über blankes eis
[Musik]
in zwei seilschaften machen sich die
jungen alpinistinnen da lernen die
eiswand zu bezwingen und haben dabei
ziemlich unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen an erscheint die höhe
nichts anzuhaben
[Musik]
vor einem jahr hat sie die matura
bestanden und studiert seither
materialwissenschaften
ja es ist einfach so dass wir eigentlich
in dem kletter verein kennengelernt
haben also vor längerer zeit und im
klettern gegangen sind und als seien
alle da war musste die einfach mit uns
weil wir auch wir sind dann umgezogen
hatten hier nie in babysitter und dann
gab's eingestellt und dann kamen sie mit
am anfang war dass wir uns auch
egoistischen bisschen was hören wir
wollten uns nicht aufgeben und dann
haben wir auch nicht gefragt und sie
musste einfach mit kommen
temperament würde ich sagen sie es ihren
stilles mittel immer gewesen also still
vom vom reden so aber aber sehr
bewegungsdrang wörtlich sie spricht kurz
und knapp heute denke ich manchmal der
wissenschaftliche typ beschreibt mein
einsatz das ist die antwort fertig so es
ist nicht schwierig also endlich ja lisa
und anne sind auch in der schweiz oft
gemeinsam in den bergen unterwegs und
ein eingespieltes team
[Applaus]
weil ich nicht so viel sein
also wenn ich das tor bekommt ist kann
es also passieren
ein ganzkörper pumpen ganz bald ganz
[Applaus]
wenn wir das seil das abitur also doch
gelegentlich völlig egal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ramona hat den vorstieg übernommen und
installiert auf dem eisfeld im
alleingang ganze vier seillängen
[Musik]
beinahe schon fast gar nicht bewusst
dass sie keine frau hört bei mir ja kurz
vor dem gipfel warten sie auf die andere
hälfte des teams
auch caro gönnt sich eine kurze rast
bevor sie alle gemeinsam die letzten
meter zum gipfel zelebrieren
der gipfel des mit theke 5500 meter über
meer ein großartiger erfolg für das
frauen expeditionsteam
die bergsteigerinnen aus der schweiz
sind die ersten westlichen frauen die
diesen gipfel erklommen haben
[Musik]
nur gerade zehn minuten verbringen die
alpinistinnen auf dem gipfel
sie wollen das heikle rechtzeitig vor
dem eindunkeln erreichen
[Musik]
nach einer nacht auf 4700 metern höhe
geht es morgen in space camp zurück die
alpinisten sind lange vor tagesanbruch
aufgestanden
in den ice wenden die heute vorliegen
wird die gefahr von steinschlag mit
jeder stunde sonnenbestrahlung größe
[Applaus]
für personen und zwei sei ja das hat die
vip mobile schönstein zwei stunden
ja aber bis zu einer woche ist das team
sucht nach alternativen zum
gletscherabbruch durch den sie beim
aufstieg gekommen sind und dessen
zerklüftete eismassen nichts von ihrer
gefährlichkeit eingebüßt haben sie
versucht einen anker mit klammern zu
setzen falls das funktioniert gehen wir
auch sonst kommt sie wieder hoch auf
zähler und dann
[Musik]
li tian bricht das unterfangen ab es ist
zu riskant für eine gruppe ich gehe da
nicht rein mit neuen leuten das habe ich
von anfang an gesagt aber wir mussten es
anschauen nicht
der fällt es nicht fest genug und an den
seiten sind wir nicht vor steinschlag
geschäft
wir haben mit rachel versuchte ein seil
an der seite zu fixen aber es wären zu
viele steine auf nicht gefallen und nach
den felsigen stellen wäre es immer noch
weit
trotzdem danke kein problem war
interessant tut mir leid dass es nicht
geklappt hat war ein versuch wert
[Musik]
wohl oder übel müssen sie die
nächstbeste option nehmen den unsicheren
weg durch den gletscherabbruch dessen
eismassen ständig in bewegung sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der abbruch ist geschafft das team hat
die ice schlucht unbeschadet passiert
[Musik]
nach vier tagen in eis und schnee kommen
sie in der tal zurück insgesamt über
1700 höhenmeter haben sie überwunden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mintec ist ein wunderschöner berg wir
haben schon als wir in das tal haben
gedacht wow was für eine pyramide aus
eis und schnee
wir haben untereinander diskutiert dass
er eine super option wäre im tal leben
unserem ich bin sehr glücklich dass wir
alle zusammen davos sind als ganzes team
ja nur irgendwie jetzt fehlt eigentlich
mit einer ziemlich gestartet sie als
förderung entdecker bereichere fegebank
vertieft aktas und material und alles
und die weiß nicht ob plüsch und und das
hat dann als jesus statt abschottung
umkehren und man einfach probieren und
schlussendlich ist kommt ich glaube so
zu einem gipfel erreicht so viele sachen
stimme also gesund und weiter uns team
und jeder sein so teammitglied und er
glaubt auch anrufe mit dem fachtreffen
trauer
das ist kein grund und das vielleicht
auch noch bedeckt und ist geschützt
das ist ausbildungsleiter silber freute
es wie die frauen in den letzten jahren
zu einem team zusammengewachsen sind
nicht immer noch mal mit kollegen und es
war noch einmal über diskutiere was ist
besser für sonneberg stiegen ist aber
maschinen nicht schlecht wenn man
[Musik]
soziale unverträglichkeiten
da ich aber aufhören wenn aber die danke
schlussendlich entspricht auch nicht an
[Musik]
für form von assad
die gruppe eigentlich verein ist es
darum geht zu bringen waren nach
interesse und das tango und seine mädels
ziehen wo sie das miteinander gibt vor
reicht das mit verschafft und das bei
dem sie mal vielleicht steigt und die
angel nicht so viel gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
während sich um das essen kümmert
genießt ali die gesellschaft der frauen
[Musik]
roth
gut
[Musik]
und da bietet
auch nach den strapazen der tour sind
die jungen frauen noch lange nicht
ausgepowert
[Musik]
so ziemlich lustig die entwicklung zu
sehen
anfangs waren sie schüchtern sie fragten
sich wohl
wer sind diese frauen die 25 jahre alt
und nicht verheiratet sind und keine
kinder haben
es ist ein ziemlich unnatürliches
konzept
[Musik]
meist sind gehört zum beispiel ein aaa
-rating und ihr halten wir im süden oder
in freiheit irgendwie mit 19 das erste
kind kam im sinne einer kultur weil es
möglich zum 25
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die heimische frauen ist im umgang aber
sie jetzt im jahr nach und wirtschaft
entwickelt dass frauen expeditionsteam
des schweizer alpenclubs plant die
letzten touren in kirgistan bergführerin
caro ist bei der besprechung nicht dabei
für das letzte abenteuer tragen die
jungen alpinistinnen die verantwortung
ganz alleine die bezwingung des 5500
meter hohen decke war ein erfolg für das
ganze team
jetzt werden unterschiedliche
bedürfnisse stärker während die einen in
den beeindruckenden granit hängen weiter
hinten im tal ihr glück suchen wollen
bevorzugen die anderen eine mixtur auf
einen der umliegenden 5000
das team will gemeinsam einige kilometer
weiter ins tal hinauf maschine dann
gehen sie getrennte wege
ramona und anne nehmen sich den pieks
wie vor den die franzosen gipfel getauft
haben
die die an florence und rahel wollen
über eine granit wahl zum picasso
aufsteigen
[Musik]
er sieht wirklich gut aus auch der fels
auf der rechten seite der flanke und da
hat sie mir
[Musik]
lisa hat ihre kolleginnen bis hierher
begleitet auf die teilnahme an einer der
beiden touren muss sie leider verzichten
[Applaus]
reilly die an und florence gehen über
die gletscher moräne weiter zum picasso
barth führerin caro und expedition
ärztin miriam sind mit von der partie
caro möchte sich die möglichkeit zum
klettern am fels nicht entgehen lassen
ramona und anne beginnen den aufstieg
zum peak sri dem franzosen gipfel eine
gemischte französische expedition ist
früher im jahr am vorgipfel des pixi
gescheitert für alpinistinnen aus dem
westen wäre es eine erstbesteigung
[Musik]
das team pikachu nähert sich über die
gletscher moräne allmählich dem ende des
tals und den einträglichen granit wänden
auf die religion und florence es
abgesehen haben
das ist so perfekt du folgst der riß
linie die ein bisschen tiefer ist um
kommst oben rechts raus ich weiß dass
ich weniger gut kletterer als ihr aber
ich weiß auch dass sie das unbedingt
machen wollte
ich bin halt nicht so gut wie hier aber
wärst du bereit ist zu versuchen und
wenn es einfach ist machst du den
vorstieg und wer nicht folgst du das
habe ich am in tegel gemacht ich bin
nicht vor gestiegen weil es nicht mein
thema im moment war ich sicher
enttäuscht wenn ich zurückdenke und
vergleiche ist es die gleiche situation
es ist sowieso sehr hohe potenziale der
wand und
also leute
die optimisten haben im juli die
pessimisten sagen dass es nicht möglich
ist dass man es nicht versuchen sollte
mallorca heißt einen schritt nach dem
anderen nehmen und dann entscheiden
ursprünglich hatte daher eine verkaufs
lehre bei einem outdoor ausrüster
absolviert heute trainiert sie die
nächste generation von alpinisten noch
zwei wochen im klettergurt kraft und
noch schlussendlich zum laptop trikot
wie ich die ganze firma in der stube in
auch kritischen dosis behandelt
ja wenn es möglich gezielt bis möglichst
miteinander und sie steht wieder bis
jüngst ist setzen wir einen lieferanten
vortrag sie das für die erste mal
überhaupt und kletterer tags ist ein
evergreen stellen klettergarten denn
eine abseitsstellung gerichtet die
reporter sowie die grünen wien und den
111 hinab zum ersten mal die hans k und
dann haben wir dagegen zum bergsteiger
am fuß des picacho erreicht sie an
erster funkspruch von ramona und anne
auf der gegenüberliegenden talseite
[Musik]
alles mit genuss eines hofgangs patrone
es wäre außerdem smog
[Musik]
geburtstag
rallye die an und florence beginnen am
pikachu mit der umsetzung ihres
vorhabens
sie bringen erste fixseile für den
morgigen aufstieg an
[Musik]
jetzt
schwieriges thema
[Musik]
stein
[Applaus]
und wenn das spiel aber sicher auch hier
abseits stellen sich jetzt ob sie müssen
hinter sich da durchbeißt nach manu
ginobili allein gesehen und kann allein
die immobilienmesse nicht studiert
sondern einfach die und in das ziemlich
schnell fertig ist weiß nicht ob es zu
überstürzt sich aber auf das ist wenn
man jetzt eine gas gehen und es nicht
rund läuft es einfach zu früh
und da kommt eine gefahr weil im abstand
das ist ein schlag ich immerhin wenn
jetzt das pro stunde rissen steinmeier
habe ich damit ist okay aber wenn es auf
fünf minuten
ach ja ziemlich wille da ist ja nicht so
dass wir hier läuft alles
[Applaus]
im camp des teams franzosen gipfel auf
4200 60 metern über meer ist die
improvisierte wasserbeschaffung gelungen
auch wenn der kocher natürlich vermisst
wird
gamer catalan der wildgewordene
eigentlich wie sie gehört ja bezahlt
wirklich ein volkssport motto und gab
gas
heute wollen die ramona und alles
schaffen was bisher keinem frauen team
aus dem westen gelungen ist den aufstieg
zum gut 5000 meter hohen franzosen
gipfel
[Musik]
vom fuß des picacho auf der anderen
seite des tals beobachten florence und
median das vorankommen der beiden
dann startet auch das team pigache die
gestern angebrachten fixseile sind
wieder abmontiert der ständige
steinschlag schien ihnen zu gefährlich
jetzt haben sie eine neue linie gewählt
rund 300 höhenmeter oder sechs
seillängen müssen die alpinistinnen
heute klettern
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es ist eine gute länge nicht so
schwierig für den start auf
wunderschönen granit - lacher ist
verliert der fels an festigkeit aber den
steilen abschnitten ist der bombastisch
nicht immer einfach sich zu schützen
weil die spalten etwas offen sind aber
sonst wirklich cool
[Musik]
das ist genuss klettern
der kamin war großartig da wo es die
beste schülerin jemand haben kann
sie sagt immer macht nur ich folge euch
im moment ist sie egal ob sie gesichert
ist oder nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ramona und anne sind seit drei stunden
unterwegs
schritt für schritt nähern sie sich dem
vorgipfel zum pixel auf knapp 4800
metern über meer den ersten vorgipfel
haben anne und ramona recht hier musste
im frühjahr eine französische expedition
umkehren
ab jetzt ist die route wenigstens für
alpinistinnen aus dem westen begangenes
terror
[Musik]
und dann stehen sie kurz vor mittag auf
dem gipfel des pikes wie
[Musik]
und wünsche ganz sicheren abstieg würde
ich durchaus interessant ist sich
einfach mal richtig sagt sie
normalerweise internet berichtet war
manchmal gleich vor mann ertrank
beispiel ist das nach einem bewusst ist
das scheiße wir werden sie besser und
was ich jetzt einfach so ja ich denke
mal wachsen vor allem luxus 20 schon
viel erfahrung macht aber wenn wir sind
im wahlkampf aber es läuft nicht so wie
man hat nur heißen für ein nicht noch
einmal nach blieb und sich sowieso ja
eigentlich ist gar nicht so tragisch
meistens muss gefühle und zuversicht
damals funktionierte schon da auch
wichtig aber man merkt einfach menschen
mega finanzkrise und ist in gold
funktioniert am abend dann dürfen sich
die kirgisischen köche auch einmal
bedienen lassen
mit foto aus der schweiz
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hier leben wir komplett im moment das
ist sehr erholsam die leute zu hause
sagen du gehst in die berge du studierst
du bist wahnsinnig du wirst müde sein
körperlich ist es vielleicht hart aber
für den kopf ist es unglaublich
entspannt weil wir im jetzt leben
das sind vier wochen expeditionen
man kann sie waschen so oft man will die
fingernägel bleiben schwarz ich freue
mich jetzt richtig drauf weiter auf
expedition zu gehen
diese erste erfahrung für mich war super
positiv
die werden wahrscheinlich in kleineren
gruppen dienen
aber dies hier wird die tür öffnen für
weitere expeditionen in der zukunft mit
dem team
wenn das jetzt plötzlich gibt
[Musik]
etwas haben die alpinistinnen aus der
schweiz noch vor bevor sie ihr geliebtes
tal verlassen und die heimreise antreten
[Musik]
dann
nach zwei tages menschenrecht das team
wieder sarikas erschöpft aber glücklich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist das beste sandwich das ich je
hatte und niemand wird das glauben zeit
um abschied zu nehmen von den bergen und
tälern kirgistans
und den guides die zu freunden geworden
sind
[Musik]
beim handel